&gt;&gt; So Andy, when you were talking to Susan, you mentioned nearsightedness. Now,
what did you mean by that?
&gt;&gt; So, people who are nearsighted have a hard time seeing things that are far
away. They can only see things that are close, or near to them.
&gt;&gt; So, Andy, are you nearsighted? You have the.
&gt;&gt; Yes. When I take my glasses off I really can't see a thing.
&gt;&gt; So, why does that happen?
&gt;&gt; Before we get into that why don't we learn a little bit more about the eye.
&gt;&gt; So, just take a look at this diagram.
&gt;&gt; Okay. Well, I've definitely seen this before. Can you tell the viewers at home
what's going on?
&gt;&gt; Okay. So, this is our eye, and the job of the eye is basically to take light
which enters here and focus it onto the back of the eye, back here.
&gt;&gt; Is it kind of how a magnifying glass focuses light?
&gt;&gt; Yeah, sort of. Now, a properly functioning eye with good vision will take light
that enters, and bend that later or focus it on to the back of the eye here,
which is called the retina.
&gt;&gt; And what about an eye that's not functioning so well. Well in that case the
lense, this part here that actually bent the light and focused it, isn't doing
it's job right. And people who are what's called nearsighted, the light
actually gets bent too much by the lense. So, maybe the focusing point would be
somewhere here, which is not where the retina is. So, this results in blurry
vision.